[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله معكم محمود براد
وفي الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع احداث
وتتفاعل اخرى بدايتنا من نيويورك وتحديدا
مبنى الامم المتحده حيث عقد مجلس الامن
جلسه مشاورات مغلقه بشان الانقلاب في
النيجر الى الخرطوم وعلى وقع اشتباكات
مستمره بين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريع في مواقع عده من العاصمه ومدنها
الثلاث وفي مواضيع الحصاد هذه الليله
قائد الحرس الرئاسيه تولى السلطه في
النيجر بعد الانقلاب اداره افريقيه ومجلس
الامن الدولي يبحث الازمه المستشار الخاص
لرئيس النيجر المعزول يقول للجزيره ان
الشعب لا يوافق على الانقلاب ويؤكد ان
الرئيس على اتصال مع مسؤولين بالخارج
يقدمون له الدعم ماكرون يحذر من التداعيات
والبيت الابيض يقول انه يدين اي جهد
للاستيلاء على السلطه بالقوه ويحذر من
توقف شراكه واشنطن ونيابل
في ختام قمه سان بطرسبرج بوتين يقول ان
موسكو والدول الافريقيه تتعهد بتعزيز نظام
متعدد الاقطاب ويبدي استعداده للتفاوض مع
الجانب الاوكراني ومن كييف زيلينسكي يقول
انه بحث مع رئيس الوزراء القطري صيغه
السلام وخطوات ضمان امن الغذاء العالمي
ورئيس الوزراء وزير الخارجيه القطريه يدعو
لابقاء كل قنوات الاتصال مفتوحه لحل
الازمه
وفي التطورات الميدانيه اوكرانيا تقول ان
مبنى شاهقا واخرا لاداره امن الدوله تعرضا
لقصف روسي في دينيبرو وتؤكد انها ستبذل
جهدها لمعاقبه موسكو
السلطات الروسيه تعلن اعتراض صاروخين
اوكرانيين في الجنوب الغربي اتتحدث عن
جرحى اثر انفجار في مقهى بمدينه تاجند في
مقاطعه روستو
على وقع الاشتباكات المستمره بين الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع الدعم ينشر
مقطع فيديو لحميتي يقول فيه ان تغيير
قياده الجيش سيؤدي الى التوصل الى اتفاق
خلال 72 ساعه
تعبر عن قلقها بشان تقارير تفيد بان فاجنر
نقلت نظم دفاع جوي الى السودان عبر
افريقيا الوسطى
هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهر على الشاشه
لقائنا على المنصات الرقميه تجدد يوميا
ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله
عربيا ودوليا
[موسيقى]
وفي الحصاد ايضا
اثنى تقول ان الحرائق في اليونان تحت
السيطره وتؤكد انها ما زالت في حاله
استمفار لمواجهه اي طارق
[موسيقى]
اعلنها الانقلابيون في النيجر تشكيل مجلس
وطني لحمايه الوطن يتولى المهام التشريعيه
والتنفيذيه الى حين العوده الى النظام
الدستوري المعلق وفي اول ظهور له منذ
الانقلاب على الرئيس بازون دعا رئيس الحرس
الرئاسي الذي اعلن نفسه رئيسا للمجلس
الانتقالي في البلاد دعا الشعب الى الهدوء
والتحلي بالمسؤوليه كما ذكر بان اخر
للانقلابيين سلسله اجراءات تتضمن تعليق
العمل بالدستور ونشاط الاحزاب السياسيه
محذرا من عواقب اي تدخل خارجي
انتظر حتى اليوم الثالث للانقلاب ليخاطب
شخصيا شعب النيجر نيجيريان
نيجيريان الجنرال عبد الرحمن تياني قائد
الحرس الرئاسي الذي اطاح بالرئيس محمد
بازوم يعلن نفسه رئيسا يعرف بالمجلس
الوطني لحمايه الوطن في بيانه الاول
المتلفز عدد اسباب عزل الرئيس ومن بينها
تدهور الوضع الامني الاقتصادي دعي
للمواطنين الى الهدوء والتحلي بالمسؤوليه
يوم الاربعاء شكلت قوات الامن والدفاع
المجلس الوطني لحمايه الوطن ووضعت حدا
لنظام الجمهوريه السابعه سن الدافع
الوحيده لهذه الخطوه هو الحفاظ على الوطن
في مواجهه التدهور المستمر للحاله الامنيه
في بلادنا من ناحيه ومن ناحيه اخرى لوقف
الانهيار الاقتصادي الناجم عن سوء اداره
الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه للبلاد لا احد
ينكر وجود شرخ في النيجر وان كثرت الم
مؤيده للانقلابيين والقليل المعروف عن
الرجل القوي في البلاد الان هو انه عين
رئيسا للحرس الرئاسي عام 2011 من قبل
الرئيس يوسف محمد الذي خلفه بازو بازو حتى
هذه اللحظه محتاجه في الجناح العسكري
للقصر الرئاسي تمكن منذ عزله في التحدث
هاتفيا مع اكثر من رئيس ومسؤول دولي وذكر
اخر بيان لينقلبيين سلسله من القرارات
منها تعليق العمل بدستور عام 2010 وحل كل
المؤسسات المنبثقه عنه تعليق نشاطات
الاحزاب السياسيه حتى اشعار اخر وتولي
المجلس الوطني لحمايه الوطن المهام
التشريعيه والتنفيذيه الى حين العوده الى
النظام الدستوري
ايضا على التحذير مجددا من اي تدخل اجنبي
في شؤون البلاد
بعض الشخصيات البارده السابقه والتي تتحصل
في القنصليات تسير في منطق المواجهه
بالتعاون مع تلك القنصليات نحذر من
العواقب التي ستنجم عن اي تدخل اجنبي
المعني الاول بهذا التحذير فرنسا
المستعمره السابقه التي تنشر اكثر من 1500
جندي في النيجر تحت غطاء مكافحه الجماعات
الجهاديه في منطقه الساحل الافريقي هزيج
الفرحين بالانقلاب في شوارع النيامي لا
تعكس كل الصوره في بلد يعاني ازمه كثيره
قبل استيلاء العسكر على السلطه بالقوه
السيناريوهات المنطقيه لما بعد الان لا
تبعثوا على الاطمئنان
قال نائب المندوبه البريطانيه في مجلس
الامن جيمس كاريوكي ان هناك شعورا بان
المجلس موحد في السعي لاذاذه ما حدث في
النيجر واضاف المسؤول البريطاني ان جميع
اعضاء المجلس عبروا خلال جلسه مشاورات
مغلقه لبحث الاوضاع في النيجر عاد الحاجه
الى عوده الديمقراطيه الدستوريه للبلاد
على حد قوله
جميع الدول الاعضاء في المجلس عبرت عن
مخاوفها بشان الوضع واعربت عن ضروره
استعاده الديمقراطيه الدستوريه وادانت ما
حدث لذا لدينا شعور قوي للغايه بان المجلس
متحد في السعي الى الادانه والتحرك ما
زلنا نعمل على بيان قدمت الدول الافريقيه
الثلاث الاعضاء في المجلس مشروع بيان في
وقت سابق وهو قيد المناقشه نامل ان يتم
اصداره في اقرب وقت ممكن
قبل الحصاد كنت قد اجريت مقابله مع انتن
كار الحسن المستشار الخاص للرئيس المعزول
محمد بازوم وسالته اولا عن الاتصالات التي
اجرها الرئيس المعزول مع قاده الدول
الاجنبيه بعد الانقلاب عليه
نعم
الاجراء اتصالات مع كل المسؤولين
الخارجيين وكلهم قدموا له الدعم مئه
بالمئه
وبالتالي هم عيدوه كما انه يحظى بدعم كل
الشعب النيجيريا على سبيل المثال من
المسؤولين الفرنسيين وهم اعلى الاصوات
استنكارا للانقلاب من منهم تحدث معه
الرئيس مع رئيس ماكرون مثلا
نعم على سبيل المثال
ما اتصل بماكرون تسويه المتحده وبغيره
وعده دول اخرى
وهنا في داخل النيجر
السكان والشعب غير موافقون على غير
موافقين على ما حصل وخاصه لان هذا
الانقلاب
قد حصل في وقت نجد فيه
انه كانت هناك مثل هذه الاعمال سابقا
ومن بين كل الدول هذه النيجر هي التي
والدوله الوحيده التي نظمت انتخابات
وعمليه انتقاليه سياسيه
والرئيس السابق غادر السلطه وسلم السلطه
لرئيس جديد الذي يقوم باداره جيده جدا
للبلاد ولا نجد اي سبب في يومنا هذا
لقيام بعض العسكريين للخروب خروج والقيام
بهذا الانقلاب
لقد طرحت اسئله كثيره حول الموضوع ولم يرد
عليها واليوم نحن حوالي سعر الحادي عشر
صباحا
كان هناك جنرال الذي قام بالانق وهو رئيس
الحرس الجمهوري خرج الى شاشه التلفزيون
ليلقي كلمات ويقدم تصريحا اعلن فيه بانه
رئيس الدوله
وفي خطابه هذا
وكانت هناك الكثير الملاحظات التي هي تهدد
الوحده الوطنيه في البلاد
وقد تحدث عن الهجوم على مناطق معينه وانا
وعلى بعض العرقيات وانا هنا هذه العقيات
الذين قالوا انهم قد تعرضوا الهجوم هو لم
يكن ذلك سيد الانتقال قلت انه ليس هناك اي
سبب لهذه الخطوه لكن الجنرال تشان قائدا
انقلاب اشار الى جمله من الاسباب منها
التدهور الامنيه والاقتصادي وقال ان اداره
الرئيس بازون اعتادت على طمئنه المواطنين
النيجريين والقول ان كل شيء على ما يرام
وهو ابعد ما يكون عن ذلك هل فاجاكم
الانقلاب
اخي محمد انتم في قناه الجزيره اخاطبكم
جميعا ان رئيس هذا الانقلاب لم لم يقل
الحقيقه عندما كان هنا هجوم على على هذه
القبيله هو كان رئيس الجمهوري وانا من هذه
العرق وقد القي بي في غياب بسجون وبالتالي
هذا ليس بالراي الذي يمكن ان يصدقه كما ان
لم يكن بازوقه انذاك هو الرئيس بل كان
الرئيس الذي قبله عندما حصل تلك المشاكل
مع بعض القبائل لماذا لم يحاسب هو ذلك
الرئيس اذا
ثم التحدث عن وضع الامني منذ ان وصل بازوم
الى السلطه هو
الذي حقق الكثير
وحسن الوضع الامني في البلاد ولم يسرقوا
اي شخص مثل هذا الانجاز
وعند وصول الى سده الرئاسه لم يهاجم اي
قبيله او اي عرقه
وبالتالي
الزعيمه العسكري لم يقل الحقيقه بل قال
اشياء غير حقيقيه وتحدث عن تحرير
تحرير سته سبعه ارهابيين كلا ليس هناك مثل
هذه الشيء
الارهابي الذي الذي اطلق سلاحي كان كان
كان
شخصا ضمن مجموعه وان النينجا
تدعو الى ضروره تحقيق السلام ولذلك
فالرئيس اتصل بهؤلاء
وطلب منهم تحقيق العداله وتحرير بعض
الاسرى لانه كانوا قد وقعدوا بان السلام
عذرا للمقاطعه
ان الرئيس بحاله جيده وانه على تواصل مع
العالم الخارجي ولم ترق الدماء كما يحدث
في انقلاب او كما حدث في انقلابات سابقه
في القاره الافريقيه كذلك انت تتحدث الان
بكل حريه من العاصمه نيامي هل تعتقد ان
الامور ستثير بمثل هذه الثلاثه بعد تعليق
العمل بالدستور الدستور وحل المؤسسات في
الدوله وان الامر سيستتب شيئا فشيئا
بالرهان على الوقت للمجموعه الانقلابيه
وضع الانقلابيين حاليا
لم يكن هناك صفق للدماء ولكن اقوالهم
اليوم والتصريح هؤلاء الذي قام بهذه
انقلاب
قال كلاما يمكن يسير مشاكل ويثير الحرائق
لانه تحدث عن عن تجنيد شباب من نيجيريين
بعض الشباب
هم حتى ان حكومه اسيكا هو الذي كان قد
حررهم وليس الرئيس بازون
وكان بعض خمسه من هؤلاء وخمسه من الاخرين
لماذا لم يطرحوا انقلاب ضد النظام السابق
والذين جرى تعيينهم ايضا للجرين وهو نفسه
وان الرئيس هيئه الاركان كان يعرف ذلك
وهو الذي كان قد اقترح تجنيدها او لا
الخمسه وقال انهم يتمتع الكفاءه عاليه جدا
عند
معارك ضد الارهابيين وبدي انا شخصيا ارى
ان ما قاله
هي اقوال مثيره للقلق والمشاكل
وبالتالي اعتقد انه كلامه يعتبر طائفي
وامور لا يمكن قبوله وبالتالي لا وبالتالي
فان رئيس
هذا الانقلاب
ينبغي ان يحرص على وحده نيجيري نيجيريا
ولم يتحرك ويتصرف بها مثل هذا الشكل
وبالتالي اذا ما تابعتم
في مقابلته اجراها اليوم التي قام بها
اليوم
كان يقول اشياء غير حقيقيه وعدها ذلك اين
كان هو هو كان هو كان في العريس الحارس
الرئاسي فلماذا عندما اراد العسكريين ان
الخيار بانقلاب ضد الرئيس السابق
لماذا لم يصل الى السلطه لماذا لماذا
رفاقه والذين
النيجر لماذا
لماذا لم يستنكرهم لماذا لم يقوموا باطاحه
بالنظام السابق
وما الذي حصل اليوم ما الذي قام به الرئيس
بازون الرئيس بازوم هو حاليا يدير البلاد
بشكل جيد
وانا شخصيا كنت معارض شديد
محمد
حدثتنا من العاصمه النيجريه نيامي شكرا
جزيلا
[موسيقى]
كانت حاضره في مدينه سانت بطرسبرجا
الروسيه خلال القمه الروسيه الافريقيه
التي شاركت فيها 49 دوله من القاره حيث
دنى رئيس الاتحاد الافريقي غزالي عثماني
ما وصفها بالتغييرات غير الدستوريه في
النيجر معتبرا ان التحولات غير الدستوريه
ليست مفيده للدول الافريقيه والشركائها من
رئيس روسيا فلاديمير بوتين فقد اكد اهميه
تنامي دور القاره السياسي والاقتصادي
ودورها كذلك في عالم متعدد الاقطاب
مشهد لم تنجحي الضغوط الغربيه براي موسكو
في تحيده
احترام المصالح والتعاون في عالم متعدد
الاقطاب تكون افريقيا احد مراكزه شكل
العنوان العريض للقمه الروسيه الافريقيه
الثانيه في سانت بطرسبرج
اود ان انوه بان القاره الافريقيه اصبحت
امام اعيننا مركزا جديدا للقوه وان دورها
السياسيه والاقتصادي ينمو بشكل كبير
وسيتعين على الجميع اخذ هذا الواقع
الموضوعي بالاعتبار
الى جانب التعاون الاقتصادي ركزت القمه
بشكل كبير على قضايا امن القاره الافريقيه
ونزاعات الداخليه ومكافحه الارهاب وجاء
انقلاب النيجر ليكون مثالا تردد صداه بقوه
في اروقه الاجتماعات معكم نقيم موقف
شركائنا من خلال عدم التدخل في شؤوننا
الداخليه ونطلب منهم الوقوف الى جانبنا في
مواجهه التغييرات غير الدستوريه يدين
الاتحاد الافريقي التغييرات غير الدستوريه
التي حدثت في النيجر
احتياجات القاره الافريقيه من الغذاء
والحبوب احتلت مركز الصداره في قمه
بطرسبورغ روسيا وعدت بتلبيه هذه
الاحتياجات وبشكل مجاني للدول الاكثر فقرا
في القاره بغض النظر عن توقف مبادره البحر
الاسود التي لم تراعي بحسب موسكو الشروط
الروسيه وحاجات الدول الافريقيه
الحديث يدور عن طرق امداد بديله للحبوب
الروسيه الى دول القاره الافريقيه خصوصا
الفقيره منها روسيا مستعده كما قال الرئيس
بوتين لتلبيه احتياجات افريقيا وتعويضها
عما لا يمكن ان يصلها من الحبوب
الاوكرانيه تريد موسكو القول انها عائده
بقوه وطويله الى افريقيا عوده تواجه
بمقاومه دول غربيه طالما اعتبرت افريقيا
مجالا حيويا لها لا غنى عنه
ووسط هذا الاستقطاب تقف افريقيا امام تحدي
بشان مدى قدرتها على ان تصبح قوه عالميه
مؤثره وليست مجرد الساحه التنافس وصراع
بين الكبار زاور الجزيره
الحديث عن التفاوض بشان الحرب الروسيه في
اوكرانيا وصيغ السلام كان حاضرا فيكي اذ
اليوم ايضا حيث قال الرئيس الاوكراني انه
اجرى لقاء مثمرا مع رئيس الوزراء وزير
الخارجيه القطري الشيخ محمد بن عبد الرحمن
الثاني وانهما ناقشا الخطوات اللازمه
لضمان الامن الغذائي العالمي واستمرار
مواصله العمل الامن لممر الحبوب اضافه
انهما ناقشا كذلك صيغه السلام وعوده
الاطفال الذين رحلتهم روسيا بشكل غير
قانوني بالاضافه الى مناقشه خطه اعاده
اعمار اوكرانيا والاستثمارات القطريه
اجتماعا مهما اليوم مع رئيس الوزراء
القطري في كييف وكانت مباحثات مثمره
للغايه والاهم من ذلك ان قطر ستكون معنا
في تنفيذ صيغه السلام وتنضم الى الجهود
العالميه المشتركه اتفقنا على التعاون من
اجل عوده الاطفال الاوكرانيين الذين تم
ترحيلهم الى روسيا كما ناقشنا وضع مبادره
حبوب البحر الاسود من المهم جدا الا يكون
هناك نقص وازمات تثيرها روسيا في سوق
الغذاء العالمي فهذه مساله استقرار عالمي
واتوجه بالشكر لقطر على موقفها المسؤول
من جانبه قال رئيس الوزراء وزير الخارجيه
القطريه الشيخ محمد بن عبد الرحمن الثاني
خلال لقائه الرئيس الاوكراني ان بلاده
تدعم الاستقرار وسلامه اراضي اوكرانيا
وسيادتها
اريد ان اكرر موقف قطر الذي لم يتغير نحن
ندعم سياده اراضي اوكرانيا وسلامتها وقطر
ملتزمه بهذا الموقف المهم المتخذ منذ زمن
طويل وهذا الموقف القطري لن يتغير
كان رئيس الوزراء وزير الخارجيه القطري قد
اعلن تقديم مساعدات انسانيه بقيمه 100
مليون دولار لاوكرانيا ومساهمه دوله قطر
بعشرين مليون دولار لدعم مبادره تصدير
الحبوب الاوكرانيه بهدف مساعده البلدان
الافريقيه في الحصول على الصادرات
الغذائيه من هذه المنطقه وشدد رئيس
الوزراء وزير الخارجيه القطري على ضروره
وقف القتال وحمايه المدنيين
واكدنا استعداد دوله قطر الكامل للمساهمه
في اي جهد دولي واقليمي يرمي الى التوصل
لحل سلمي وفوري لهذه الازمه ونحن على يقين
بان الطريق الوحيده للنجاح في ذلك هي
ابقاء كافه قنوات الاتصال مفتوحه وفي هذا
السياق اود ان اشدد ان وقف القتال وضمان
حمايه المدنيين هي من ضمن اهم اولوياتنا
في دوله قطر
هذا واكد ماجد الانصاري مستشار الرئيس
مجلس الوزراء القطري المتحدث باسم
الخارجيه القطريه للجزيره اكد ان بلاده
منفتحه على اي جهد يمكن ان تقوم به في
اطار انهاء الازمه الاوكرانيه
منذ اليوم الاول لهذه الازمه كان الموقف
القطري هو الانفتاح على كل الجهود
الاقليميه والدوليه القائمه الى انهاء هذه
الازمه لما تمثله هذه الازمه من تاثير على
الامن والسلم العالميين وعلى
الامن الغذائي وامن الطاقه في المنطقه وفي
العالم وبالتالي كان لقطر العديد من من
الجهود التي كان على راسها مثلا دعم
مبادره
التصدير الحبوب الاوكرانيه
قنوات الاتصال مفتوحه مع الجانبين الروسي
والاوكراني خلال هذه الفتره كما تعلمون ان
المعادله الوزراء كان في موسكو مؤخرا
ملتقى بالرئيس بوتين وهو اليوم يغادر لو
كان يبعد اللقاءات طبعا كما قلنا مع
المسؤولين الاوكرانيين كلها تصب في محاوله
التفكير الجماعي والمشترك في ايجاد حلول
لهذه الازمه والابواب القطريه مفتوحه
دائما لاي جهد ممكن ان تقوم به قطر في هذا
الاطار
هذا ووصف ايفل ميكي تينكو مستشار وزير
الخارجيه الاوكراني زيارته رئيس مجلس
الوزراء وزير الخارجيه القطري الى كييف
بالحدث المهم وقال في مقابله مع الجزيره
انه استمع من رئيس الوزراء القطري الى
تاييد بلاده لسياده ووحده اراضي اوكرانيا
انا كنت سعيدا استمع من
سيد رئيس الوزراء قطري بان قطر تؤيد سياده
اوكرانيا ووحده تراضي اوكرانيه وفقي ميثاق
المتحده شيء معقول جدا
وبين يعني صيغه سلامه الاوكراني
انسحاب قوات روسيه
الى حدود 91 الى حدود 14
مئتين11
فبعدين
نشوف كيف البعده لان هناك اكيد متطلبات
اخرى لان كان اضرار ولا تزال جسيمه في
اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
الى تطورات الميدانيه اذ قال وزير
الداخليه الاوكراني انه هجوما صاروخيا
روسيا استهدف الليله مجمعا سكانيا في
مدينه دينيبرو الشرقيه اوكرانيا والحق
اضرارا بعدد من المباني قال الرئيس
الاوكراني ان مبنى شاهقا واخر لاداره امن
الدوله تعرضا لقصف روسي وان بلاده ستبذل
جهودا لمعاقبه موسكو على الاعتداء
والارهاب ضد الشعب الاوكراني حسب قوله
وفي التطورات الميدانيه ايضا قالت هيئه
الاركان الاوكرانيه ان القوات الروسيه شنت
29 غاره جويه على الاراضي الاوكرانيه خلال
الساعات الاربع والعشرين الماضيه في
المقابل اعلن نائب في مجلس الدومه الروسي
انفجار عبوه الناسفه في مصفاه نفط بمدينه
سماره الجنوبيه روسيا دون وقوع اصابات في
حين اعلنت خدمه الطوارئ الروسيه اصابه 15
شخصا نتيجه الانفجار بمقهى في مدينه تاجان
روج مقاطعه روستوف
يهتز داخل الروسي مجددا على وقع ما ترجح
السلطات انه استهداف اوكراني اكثر من نقطه
شهدت انفجارات او محاولات هجوم بمسيارات
وقعت اصابات في مدينه تاجان روج بمقاطعه
روستوف في الجنوب الروسي نتيجه انفجار
بمقهى رجح حاكم المقاطعه ان يكون ناجما عن
اطلاق صاروخ وفي مدينه سماره الى الجنوب
ايضا انفجرت عبوه الناسفه في مصفاه نفط
دون ان تسجل اصابات بينما اعلنت وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه تدمير مسيره اوكرانيه كانت
تحاول مهاجمه منشات في مقاطعه موسكو نافيه
وقوع خسائر في الداخل الاوكراني نفذت
القوات الروسيه هجمات عديده منها في
مقاطعه خاركيف وتحديدا محور كوبيانسك وفق
المتحدث باسم قوات الغرب بالجيش
الروسياق الاعمال العسكريه باتجاه
كوبيانسك وجهت الق وات الصاروخيه لمجموعه
قوات الغرب ضربه صاروخيه في منطقه
بلاغوداتانا كما وجهت قوات الدبابات ضربات
الى وحدات اللواء الميكانيكي في مناطق من
خاركيف ادت الى تدمير عدد من الاليات
العسكريه
وتتحدث هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه عن 29
غاره روسيه واكثر من 70 قذيفه صاروخيه
خلال الساعات الماضيه كما اعلنت القوات
الروسيه صدى هجوم للقوات الاوكرانيه في
زابوريا وتدمير عدد من الاليات العسكريه
الاوكرانيه واكد بيان لوزاره الدفاع قصف
مواقع للقوات الاوكرانيه في سيفريسك
بالقرب من بخموت التي يتحدث الجانب
الاوكراني عن تقدم تدريجي جنوبي المدينه
التقدم التدريجي مستمر جنوبي بخموت اما في
المناطق الشماليه للمدينه فتصدت قواتنا
لهجمات العدو وفي اتجاه كوبيانس كوليمان
يحاول الجيش الروسي اشغال قواتنا عن
معاركنا الناجحه في بخمر ويهدف دون جدول
اجبار قواتنا على التراجع من المرتفعات
التي تسيطر عليها
هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه بدورها قالت ان
قواتها سيطرت على قريه ستارو مايوي انقطعت
لمحاولات تقدم روسيه في الايمان في
المقاطعه نفسها بينما نفذت القوات
الاوكرانيه هجوما على محوري
في مقاطعه
معنى من كيف بصير هيك كوزان المستشار في
وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه ومعنى من موسكو
السيد باسيلي فاتيجاروف ضابط الاحتياط في
الجيش الروسي مرحبا بكما السيد كوزان
استهداف الداخل الروسي صرح حدثا متكررا هل
يشير ذلك الى تحول في استراتيجيه اوكرانيا
هل تسع كييف لنقل المعركه الى الداخل
الروسي
[موسيقى]
لوطنك
مشكله في ترجمه كلام الضيف دعنا اذا سيد
كوزان نتحول الى ضيفنا من موسكو السيد
فاتيجاروف والسؤال ايضا للسيد فاتيجاروف
هل تلمحون ملامح تحول في استراتيجيه
اوكرانيا بنقل هجومها الى الداخل الروسي
او اشراك اراضي روسيا في المعركه الدائره
ساعيد السؤال عليك ضيفنا ان لم تكن قد
سمعته
ساعيد السؤال مره اخرى هل تلمحون تغيرا في
استراتيجيه اوكرانيا من خلال الهجمات
المتكرره على الاراضي الروسيه
في الواقع ان الاستراتيجيه لا تتغير من
الطرف الاوكراني للاسف نحن مضطرين ان
نعترف بهذا ان الاستراتيجيه ارهابيه وهي
لا تزال كذلك هذه هي الضربه كانت اليوم ضد
متحف ومنزل سكاني
ومقهى ولم يستهدفوا اي منشات عسكريه ولم
تتواجد هناك اي منشات من هذا النوع شاهدته
هذه المقاطع وتواصلتم مع الاشخاص الذين
كانوا شهود عيان وتحدثنا معهم لفتره طويله
بعد هذه الهجمات هذه الهجمه ارهابيه كان
من المعجز انه لم يتضرر احد ولكن شخص واحد
تعرض لضرر وهو الان في المشفى وفي اوضاع
صعبه هذه الهجمات لا تفسر باي طريقه اخرى
اعداء انها هجمت ارهابيه
والهجمات في ضد المناطق عذرا للمقاطعه
المثير ان الرئيس الاوكراني استخدم اللفظ
ذاته لفظ الارهاب لوصف ما تقوم به روسيا
اليوم تحديدا حينما قصفت مجمعا سكانيا في
دينيبرو شرقيه اوكرانيا والحقت اضرارا
بالمباني واشار كذلك الى قصف مبنى اخر
ومبنى لاداره امن الدوله استخدم اللفظ
ذاته وهو لفظ الارهاب الروسي
ا انا سوف اوضح لك قبل كل شيء
الضربات ضد ما يسمى
بالمباني السكانيه كانت
هجمات ضد منشات عسكريه
يتم تغطيتها على انها منازل سكانيه اما
بالنسبه لضربات على مركز الاستخبارات كانت
ضربه اثناء اجتماعات خاصه ولقد دمرت هذه
المنشاه اما العماره المجاوره قد تضررت من
انظمه الدفاع الجويه
سالتك ان كان هناك تحول في الاستراتيجيه
الاوكرانيه من خلال محاوله نقل المعركه
الى الداخل الروسي لم اسمع اجابتك
اذا كان الحديث عن
ضربه في تينا هورج
فهناك اعلان رسمي بالنسبه لهذه الضربه
ونحن لا نعترف بها واريد ان اضيف هنا ان
روسيا هي من تستخدم الضربات على المناطق
الحدوديه التابعه لها حتى تقوم فيما بعد
باتهام الطرف الاوكراني واذكر ان هذا حدث
منذ اشهر عندما سقطت قنابل تزن حواري
النصف طن على
بالغرد وهذا قد سجل من قبل السكان
المحليين واحد هذه القنابل فجرت منزلا
سكانيا وقنبله اخرى لم تنفجر وهذا كان من
قبل المدفعيه
الروسيه التي تعمدت قصف ذلك القطاع لذلك
ليس هناك خلاف على ان روسيا تقوم باعمال
استفزاليه من هذا النوع حتى فيما بعد تقوم
باتهام اوكرانيا ثم
تقوم بتبرير اعمالها ويجب ان نفهم اننا
نتعامل مع الدوله الروسيه التي تقصف
المنشات السكانيه بما فيها بما فيهم بوتين
الذي جاء للحكومه بعد
الكثير من الاعمال الارهابيه التي حدثت في
موسكو التي ادت الى الكثير من الضحايا
وهذه اعمال طبيعيه لا روسيا الفيدراليه
سماد نفس اللفظ ونفس الوصف مساله الارهاب
يطلق من خلال الاوكرانيين على ما تقوم به
روسيا ما ردكم
اخالف هذا تماما ان روسيا
دوله مسؤوله ولاعب على الساحه الدوليه وهي
دوله لم تقم في تاريخها باستخدام الاساليب
الارهابيه سواء كان على ارض المعركه او
خلف اراضي المعركه او على مستوى العلاقات
ادولي على سبيل المثال اليوم وبالامس
السيد
اكد بالنسبه لخروجه من اتفاق الحبوب سوف
نكون محايدين حول دول افريقيا وسوف نكون
انسانيين في التعامل مع الدول
الرئيس بوتين لكن على ارض الواقع قلت ان
روسيا لا تستخدم هذه التكتيكات بينما شكى
السوريون من قبل بان هذه التكتيكات ذاتها
يعني اتبعت في في دعم نظام الرئيس بشار
الاسد في سوريا وكذلك طبعا موسكو وريثه
الاتحاد السوفيتي الذي استخدم التكتيكات
ذاتها مع الافغان كيف تقول ان
ليست معتاد على هذا
اعتقد ان هذه قضايا سياسيه وانا اعرف
التاريخ الروسي جيدا وانا اعلم جيدا انه
لا في افغانستان ولا في اي دوله اخرى
للاتحاد السوفيتي ولا روسيا لم يستخدموا
ابدا الاساليب
الارهابيه نحن منذ فتره طويله اصدقاء مع
روسيا مع سوريا عفوا ومع بشار الاسد الذي
جاء للحكومه بطريقه
قانونيه وروسيا تواجدت هناك بطريقه
قانونيه عن طريق دعوه الحكومه الروسيه
لروسيا امام الذي تفعله هناك امريكا فهذا
السؤال اخر والاعمال
الاستفزازيه التي تقوم بها امريكا هذا هو
الارهاب الحقيقه
حينما يقول الرئيس زيلنسي انه سيعاقب
المسؤولين او انه سيسعى لمعاقبه المسؤولين
عن استهداف الداخل الاوكراني والمنشات
المدنيه من يقصد بهذا العقاب
بالطبع الحديث هنا عن جميع
الاداره العسكريه بشكل خاص
وهم مجرمين دوليين وخاصه سيد فادي
وجميع المجرمين العسكريين الذين بداوا هذه
الحرب وهذا العدوان ضد اوكرانيا
والتي تلوثت اياديهم بدماء الابرياء
الاوكرانيين وبما فيها الهجمه التي حدثت
اليوم في مركز
ادنبرو ضد عماره وهذا ما سوف نقوم به
بما يتناسب مع القناه القوانين الدوليه
وعلى اساس قوانين المحكمه الجنائيه
الدوليه كل هذه الجرائم عاجلا ام اجلا سوف
تؤدي الى محاكمات عادله وهذا ما يتحدث
المستشار في وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه كان
معنا من كيف شكرا جزيلا لك واشكرك كذلك
ضيفنا من موسكو
ضابط الاحتياط في الجيش الروسي شكرا
[موسيقى]
افادى مراسل الجزيره بسماع دوي متقطع
لاسلحه ثقيله شمالي مدينه ام درمان وسط
اشتباكات بين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريع وافاد بان الجيش استهدف تجمعات
للدعم السريع بقصف المدفعيا في منطقه بحري
شمال الخرطوم وفي شرق النيل قال قائد قوات
الدعم السريع محمد حمدان دجله خلال ظهوره
في مقطع فيديو نشرته قواته وهو الاول منذ
اشهر قال ان قياده الجيش الحاليه تعمل وفق
توجيهات فلول النظام السابق وانه في حال
تغيير هذه القياده سيتم التوصل الى اتفاق
خلال اثنتين وسبعين ساعه
لاخواننا في القوات المسلحه
العاجل غير هذه الطقم الباقيه خير هذه
القياده بتاعه حياه الغياب دي غيروها
الليله خلال 72 ساعه
مقطع فيديو نشرته قوات الدعم السريع ويظهر
فيه قائدها محمد حمدان يتحدث ببعض قواته
دل النفا بشده في احدث ظهور علني له وجود
اي من اللصوص والمسلحين الذين يقتحمون
المنازل ومن سماهم بالمتفلتين في صفوف
قواته اعتذر للشعب السوداني جراء المعاناه
بسبب الحرب لكنه ربط الوصول الى اتفاق
بانهائها بذهاب البرهان وتغييره هيئه
قياده الجيش السوداني
والمعروف ان الجيش ظل يربط نهايه الحرب
بتسريع قوات الدعم السريع وهو ما يعني لدى
كثيرين ولو بطريقه غير مباشره ادانه
قانونيه واخلاقيه للدعم السريع تجاه احداث
لا يعترف الدعم بارتكابها اصلا
في هذه الاثناء لا تتوقف الاشتباكات بين
الطرفين ويتحدث مراسلنا عن سماع دوي متقطع
للاسلحه الثقيله شمالي مدينه ام درمان
والخرطوم بحري بينما ذكرت مصادر محليه
للجزيره ان طائرات الجيش قصفت عددا من
مواقع القوات الدعم السريع في جنوب
الخرطوم وفي شرق النيل
القوه المشتركه لحركات الكفاح المسلح
والتي كانت تقاتل نظام الرئيس المعزول عمر
البشير استنكرت انتقاد مساعد القائد العام
للجيش لوقوفها على الحياد في الحرب
الراهنه وقالت في بيان لها انها اتخذت هذا
الموقف منذ اندلاع الحرب منتصف ابريل
الماضي ودعت الحركات طرفي النزاع لضبط
قواتهما ومنع اي انتهاك بحق المواطنين
وشددت على انها لن تبقى على الحياد اذا
تعرض المواطنون
وممتلكاتهم للاعتداء في غضون ذلك نقلت
وكاله الاسطوشيات عن زعيم قبيله المساليد
في ولايه غرب دارفور وصهما حدث اخيرا في
الولايه خلال اقتحام قوات الدعم السريع
ومؤيديها لعاصمتها الجنينه بانه كان مذبحه
مخططه وهنا اكثر من 5000 شخص قتلوا واصيب
ما لا يقل عن ثمانيه الاف اخرين وان
الهجمات على الجنينه ومحيطها كان هدفها
التطهير العرقي وارتكاب الاباده الجماعيه
ضد المدنيين
بعض من تداعيات الحرب تتكشف بين يوم واخر
وفقدان الثقه هو القاسم المشترك حتى الان
بين طرفيها
معنى في الاستوديو والكاتب والمحل السياسي
السوداني الاستاذ ضياء الدين بلال مرحبا
بك لمن كانت رساله حمدان او الدعم السريع
بحسب هذا التسجيل المصور للشعب السوداني
امن البرهان قبل اطراف خارجيه
اعتقد ان هذه هي محاوله فرقعه اعلاميه او
محاوره لتضميط بعض الجراحه العسكريه التي
تعرضت لها اتعرض لها الدعم السريع في
الفتره الاخيره خاصه وانه اصبح عاجز عن
شنهيون بذات الطرق القديمه وبذات القوه
والكثافه الناريه التي كان يشنها على بعض
المناطق فهو
يدرك تماما بان هنالك حاله احباط وتدهور
للحاله النفسيه وسط الجنود في اراد بهذه
الجرعه الاعلاميه ان
يشجع جنوده وان يقول بانه موجود رغم ان
هنالك حديث كثير حديث فني عن هذا الفيديو
اذا كان مصور داخل السودان او خارج
السودان وان هنالك يمكن ان تكون بعض
العمليات الفنيه قد اجلت عليه لايصاره
كانه في داخل داخل الخرطوم او او ده بشكل
عمومي بغض النظر عن هذا الجدل لكن واضح ان
هذه الرساله اذا اردنا ان تكون رساله
عسكريه فهي لم تصل باحتبار ان الدعم
السريع من الاول يوم حدد بانه يريد القبض
على البرهان ولكنه الان يريد الاستسلام
ويريد لجهات اخرى داخل الجيش ان تقوم بهذه
المهمه وهذا اعتقد انه فشل عسكري لان بعض
100 يوم ترجع لهذه النقطه ايضا ذلك الدليل
على فشل العسكري كما انه كان لو اراد ان
يكون هنالك تكون هنالك رساله سياسيه لظهر
وسط المواطنين في ولايه الخرطوم وهو يتحدث
عن سيطره عن سيطره لا تقل عن 90% على
الخرطوم فكان اولى له ان يسهر وسط
المواطنين
نفى ايضا وجود اي من اللصوص او المنفلتين
في صفوف قواته الذين يغيرون على المنازل
ويرتكبون او ينتهكون حرمتها هل تصل هذه
الرساله في ظل الاتهامات الكثيره الموجهه
الى قواتها يصدقها الناس وحينما يقول بان
هنالك متفلتين ده دليل لان هنا لان هؤلاء
المتفلتين متفلتين من الدعم السريع وليس
متفلتين من جهه اخرى لانه كل الحثيات
والقرائن والشواهد تؤكد ذلك هو بالعكس هو
قام بتشكيل لجنه قام بتشكيل لجنه لمحاسبه
المتفلتين داخل الدعم السريع وهناك
احترافات من قبل عدد من الناطقين باسم
الدعم السريع يقولون بان هنالك تجاوزات
باعتبار ان العدد يتجاوز المئه الف وان
تجاوزات حتى قام بها الجيش الامريكي في
العراق
كغدوه بالنسبه لهم فاعتقد ان هنالك اضطراب
في هذا الامر في مره يتم نفي مطلق وفي مره
يتم احترافات محدده وفي مره تعود قياده
الدعم السريع لذات الانقار القديم ولكن
الشواهد والقرائن والفيديوهات واكبر هذه
التجاوزات توثق بالفيديوهات الخاصه
بالجنود والضباط في الدعم السريع فاذا كنت
انت تقول بانك مسيطره على 90% من المساحه
فانت مسؤول عن 90% من هذه المساحه في
الاخير الاعتذار الذي ابداه للشعب
السوداني بسبب المعاناه التي تكبدوها
السودانيون يعني من خلال امد الحرب الطويل
هل تعتقد ان هذا يعني ربما بادره حسن
النيه يمكن البناء عليها لانهاء هذه الحرب
التي تجاوزت المئه يوم نعم هذا اعتذار
مجاني لا يمكن شرائه من قبل اي طرف لان
هذه حينما تريد الاحتضار يجب ان تكف عن
التجاوزات القائمه التجاوزات لا تزال
مستمره هنالك وجود مكثف لغات الدعم السريع
في المنازل هنالك سرقات تتم بشكل كبير
للسيارات الخاصه بالمواطنين التجاوزات
مستمره والاحتذار مستمر وهذا يدل بان هذا
الاحتضاء الاحتذار
ليست له قيمه او جدوى فعليه غير انه هو
محاوره للتجميل ما هو مشوه اصلا بهذه
الممارسات التي قامت بها الدعم السريع
شكرا جزيلا لك الاستاذ ضياء الدين بلال
الكاتب والمحلل السياسي السوداني شكرا
[موسيقى]
اعلنت فرق الاطفاء في اليونان ان الحرائق
التي اجتاحت البلاد في الايام الاخيره
اصبحت تحت السيطره اليوم الجمعه وقالت
متحدثه باسم فرق الاطفاء انه لا توجد في
الوقت الراهن بؤر نيران الناشطه لكن فرق
الاطفاء ستبقي ستبقى على اهبه الاستعداد
لاحتواء النيران وتسببت الحرائق في وفاه
خمسه اشخاص وتدمير منازل ومزارع ومصانع
واحتراق الاف الهكتارات من الغابات ووصلت
حرائق الغابات الى مستودع ذخيره للقوات
الجويه اليونانيه امس بالقربه من بلده
نيه انشيالوس السياحيه
حصل بريطاني مسلم على ترخيص لتحويل جزء من
مجمع تروكاديرو الشهير في قلب العاصمه
لندن الى مسجد ومركز اسلامي جاء ذلك بعد
ثلاث سنوات من رفض طلب الترخيص لبناء
المسجد بسبب ضغوط جماعات اليمين المتطرف
الرافضه لاقامه مساجد في بريطانيا وشنت
حمله اعلاميه ضده
ما من سائح يصل الى لندن دون زياره هذا
المجمع الترفيهي الشهير صاحب هذا المبنى
رجل الاعمال البريطاني المسلم اسف عزيز
يعتزم اقامه مركز اسلامي فيه
هناك حاجه فعليه الى مركز من هذا النوع
لان المسجد المحلي صغير حيث اضطروا عدد من
المصلين الى الصلاه في الشارع وليس هناك
مكان خاص للنساء والمركز الجديد سيخفف
الضغط على المراكز المجاوره وسيدعم
المجتمع المحلي بشكل عام
لكن الحصول على ترخيص لاقامه المركز لم
يمر دون تحديات فمثل هذه التقارير
الاعلاميه التي تزعم ان المجمع الترفيهيه
بكامله سيحول الى مسجد كبير اثار معارضه
جماعات اليمين المتطرف ما ادى الى سحب طلب
الترخيص الاولي عام 2020
الخطاب الاعلامي كان خاطئا بداه احد
المتعصبين الذي زعم ان المبنى كله سيتحول
الى مسجد كبير من ثلاثه طوابق وعشرين
مئذنه وان المدينه تتحول الى لندنستان وهو
ما ادى الى كراهيه واعتراضات راينا ان
القضيه اصبحت سياسيه حينها سحبنا الطلب
وانتظرنا بضع سنوات قبل العوده لطلب
الترخيص وحصلنا على الموافقه
سكانها والعاملين فيها واقامه مسجد او
مكان عباده في اعتقادهم هو اضافه اخرى
لهذه الفسيفساء
التسامح والاحترام ضروريان والاهم ان لا
تتصادم الثقافه
سعداء المسجد هنا الجاليه
الناس زوار لندن ان شاء الله يكون خير ان
شاء الله على الرغم من الاختلاف بشان بناء
دور عباده في اماكن ترفيهم مثل حي في قلب
لندن فلا احد يختلف بان هذا التنوع
الثقافي والعرقي والديني يزيد العاصمه
ثراء ويبقى احد اسباب جذب الاستثمارات
والسياح من كل بقاع العالم مينا حرب اللغه
الجزيره لندن
[موسيقى]
الى كوريا الشماليه ورسائل عرض عسكري واسع
النطاق بحضور خارجي وسط توترات متصاعده
وتحذيرات من حرب بارده جديده حول شبه
الجزيره الكوريه فما الذي حدث
محاطا بمسؤولين روس وصينيين اشرف الزعيم
الكوري الشمالي كيم جونغ اون على ارض
عسكري في بلاده الضمه طائرات مسيره جديده
وصواريخ باليستيه عابره للقارات ذات قدره
نوويه وعبرت مقطورات تحمل على الاقل 4
طائرات مسيره عسكريه جديده صحه كيم ال
سونج في بيونج بينما حلقت اخرى فوق الموقع
في الذكرى السبعين للهدنه التي اوقفت
الحرب بين الكوريتين تخللت العرضه مجموعه
من الاسلحه الجديده كشف النقاب عن العديد
منها في معرض للمعدات الدفاعيه الاربعاء
ولاول مره عرضت الطائره المسايره الجديده
للهجوم النووي تحت الماء المس
تسونامي باللغه الكوريه وفقا لموقع ان كي
نيوز الذي يتخذه منسول مقرا له وسار الاف
الجنود وراء اقوى صواريخ باليستيه عابره
للقارات من بينها صاروخ هو سونج 18 الذي
يعمل بالوقود الصلب والذي اختبر في ابريل
نيسان ويوليو تموز هذا العام العرض
العسكري كشفت عنه وسائل اعلام كوريه
شماليه رسميه اليوم وجاري تنظيمه امس في
اليوم الذي تحتفل فيه بيونغيانج بانه يوم
النصر لكن ما الجديد الحضور تم العرض
بحضور وزير الدفاع
وعضو المكتب السياسي في الحزب الشيوعي
الصيني
وهما من اول الضيوف الاجانب الذين ابلغ عن
زيارتهم
على المستوى الرسمي منذ وباء كورونا زياره
وزير الدفاع الروسي تعد الاولى من مسؤول
دفاعي روسي كبير لكوريا الشماليه منذ انه
يار الاتحاد السوفيتي عام 1991
ظهور هؤلاء المسؤولين في فعاليات مع
الصواريخ النوويه لكوريا الشماليه يتعارض
مع ما كان يحدث في السنوات الماضيه عندما
سعت في جين وموسكو الى الناي بانفسهما عن
تطوير بيونغيانج للاسلحه النوويه
والصواريخ الفلسطينيه في هذا السياق حذر
وزير الدفاع الكوري الشمالي خلال العرض
العسكري من ان الولايات المتحده ليست
لديها فرصه للنجاه في حال استخدامها اسلحه
نوويه ضد فيونج وفي احدث كتاب ابيض لوزاره
الدفاع اليابانيه الجمعه صنفت الوزاره على
انها مصدر قلق كبير لليابان معنا من روما
السيد جوليو بوليسي الخبير
في الشؤون الصينيه في جامعه اوكسفورد
سيتوليزي في رايك من رسائل التي يمكن ان
تصل الى الغرب
وليت كذلك من خلال الحضور الصينيه الروسي
لعرض العسكريه تضمن اسلحه يحضرها مجلس
الامن الدولي الذي تشارك فيه الصين وروسيا
اكيد فان الرساله الاساسيه التي تم
ارسالها مفادها ان كوريا الشماليه هي ليست
دوله مارقه او منعزله وان
هنالك لديها دول تدعمها وخاصه روسيا
باستطاعاتها
ان تقوم بقمع العقوبات ان كلا من روسيا
وكوريا الشماليه مفروضه عليهما عقوبات
ثقيله للغايه وايضا تغيير
الممارسات
الموجوده ومحاوله
دوران على العقوبات مفروضه من الغرب اخذ
بنظر الاعتبار الضغط على الصين الصين قررت
ان ترسل
عضوا مدنيا من المكتب السياسي للحزب
الشيوعي بدلا من شخص
عسكريه وهذا ايضا ارسل رساله
مفادها ان كوريا الشماليه ليست معزوله وان
الصين ايضا لديها نوع ومستوى من التعاطف
لنظام
حينما تقول ان واشنطن ليست لديها فرصه اذا
هاجمت الاراضي الكوريه الشماليه بالاسلحه
النوويه هل تعتقد ان هذه الرساله موجهه
فعلا الى واشنطن ام الى طوكيو
اولا
اعتقد انها مرسله الى الاثنين ربما ايضا
الى كوريا الجنوبيه بمعنى
ان كوريا الشماليه لديها القدره على ان
تنتقم
تجاه اي هجوم بالتاكيد الجهه المستقبل
الاساسيه واشنطن لكن ايضا هذه هي رساله
موجهه الى جمهور المحلي داخل كوريا
الشماليه لتثبت ان النظام الكوري الشمالي
الذي شهد اوقاتا صعبه في فتره الجائحه
وكان هنالك ازمه غذاء ايضا قويه فان نظام
كم جيم الان يريدوا ان يظهر هذه النتائج
نتائج التفوق العسكري وايضا مساله تفوق في
الفضاء
بدء ان وجود دول مثل هذه مهمه مثل روسيا
والصين وحضورها في هذا العرض ايضا هذه
العروض وهذه الاحداث وكذلك التجارب
الصاروخيه المتكرره من فيونجيانغ هل تصاعد
من التوتر في شبه الجزيره الكوريه هل تزكي
او تزكي نيران حرب بارده جديده في تلك
المنطقه
اعتقد ان الحرب البارده
هي مستمره موجوده في المنطقه ليس لدينا
الان ربما
نظره واضحه وصوره واضحه لاقطاب هذه الحرب
الصين بالتاكيد
ستسمح مثلا
ان تبقي خط حياه الى او شريانه حياه الى
كوريا الشماليه لكن من المحتمل ان الصين
ستدعم نظامك شكرا جزيلا لك الخبير في
الشؤون الصينيه كان مع في جامعه اوكسفورد
كان معنا من العاصمه الايطاليه روما
[موسيقى]
جدل في بريطانيا عنوانه خطط ايواء طالبي
اللجوء فبحسب وسائل اعلام بريطانيه اشترت
وزاره الداخليه خياما قادره على ايواء
قرابه الفي طالب لجوء وتخطط لنصبها في
مواقع عسكريه مقفره بحلول نهايه اغسطس اب
هذه الخطوه تاتي بعدما زاد عدد الوافدين
الى سواحل جنوب شرقي انجلترا واثار ذلك
انتقادا للحكومه لا اعتبرت غير مستعده
وعاجزه امام حجم المهمه لكن خطه الخيام
اثارت انتقادا في صفوف الوزراء وفق صحيفه
تايمز البريطانيه التي ذكرت ان بعض
المسؤولين قارنوها بمعسكرات الاعتقال
وبعيدا عن الجدل بشان الخطط البريطانيه
لمواجهه زياده اعداد طالبي اللجوء
واستنفاذ الموارد الحكوميه والخلافات
السياسيه يراوح مازق الالاف من البشر
مكانه والامل كل الامل ان يفلح العالم في
التوصل الى خطته تحفظ للناس كرامتهم وانهم
وعيشهم الكريم كتاب الحصاد شكرا